نعم عبد الصمد الاحداث بدات منذ ليله امس
حيث تتوافذ الالاف الى ملعب جذع النخله
البعض منهم نام على رصيف الملعب ليششهد
حضور المباراه
المترقبه اليوم بين منتخبي عمان
والعراق الالاف والالاف من الجماهير
توافدوا من ما سبب اغلاقات في الطرق حالات
استنفار كثيره لاجهزه الامن العديد من
الاجهزه الامن نزلوا الى الشوارع لتنظيم
عمليه السير لكن العمليه خرجت عن السيطره
همم حاله وفاه اليوم كانت لدى همم
الجماهير همم العشرات من الجماهير اصيبوا
بسبب التدافع الذي استمر الى هذه اللحظه
طبعا تضاربت الاراء حول اعداد همم ساعه
الجمهور حول الاسباب التي ادت الى هذه
الوفاء هذه همم الى هذا التدافع البعض قال
ان
كانت بسبب سعه الملعب همم البعض بعض
المسؤولين قالوا ان السبب كان همم بسبب
عدم توفر تذاكر او التذاكر كانت التي
يبيعه اكثر من العداد المتراقبه ساعه
الملعب 65000 همم الذين حضروا الجماهير
التي حضرت خارج الملعب هم اكثر من 60 اكثر
من 65,000 همم بشكل عام همم اسعد العيداني
محافظ البصره قال ان همم
ستلغى المباراه
يتراجع الجماهير من ملعب جذع النخله
ويسهل عمليه سير ودخول الجماهير الذين
حصلوا على بطاقات الدخول حالات استمرار
كما سبق وذكرت ان في في في حول في ضواحي
ملعب النخله الاغلاقات قد بدات منذ الان
حالات استمرار لدى قوات الامن همم هناك
خيبه امل كبيره لدى الجماهير العراقيه في
حاله الغاء البطوله اليوم هناك احتماليه
كما اسلفت همم من محافظه البصره انه سيتم
الغاء همم النهائي اليوم في حاله همم لم
يستجيب الجماهير ل- همم القوات الق